Tengo una amiga,
actriz, de sesenta y tantos años,
sumamente inteligente,
fantástica,
con una gran inteligencia emocional.
Y unos días antes de Navidad, fue a la oficina postal.
Estaba llena de gente, como sucede para esa fecha
y, mientras completaba unos formularios,
muy concentrada en su tarea,
aparece alguien así, de la nada, que la aparta del camino,
físicamente, poniendo las manos sobre ella.
Parece que el hombre necesitaba algo y mi amiga le obstruía el paso,
y por eso la apartó.
Quizá él le habría dicho algo, o quizá no, o ella no lo oyó...
Como fuere, estaba concentrada completando el formulario
y, de repente, unas manos la toman
y la apartan del camino.
Luego el hombre consiguió lo que pretendía
--lo que fuera que ella le impedía obtener--
y se marchó tranquilamente.
Mi amiga admitió su conmoción al principio, naturalmente.
Y luego empezó a sentir una furia que no supo explicar:
no era fastidio,
ni frustración,
sino "furia", según sus propias palabras.
Y luego agregó,
"Quería ir a las manos,
no sé... estaba furiosa.
Y no sé por qué.
Es decir, no me golpeó,
no me lastimó,
no me insultó.
Me corrió de mi lugar,
y quise atacarlo,
o al menos, correr tras él y gritarle en la cara".
Y me quedé pensando en esa furia,
tratando de entender por qué, con solo escuchar su relato,
yo también sentí furia
y por qué esta palabra y este sentimiento
se habían vuelto tan comunes últimamente.
Me temo que en este momento de la charla
los hombres van a empezar a sentirse algo incómodos.
(Risas)
Está bien.
No se vayan.
Vengo soportando esta furia
desde la última elección presidencial en Estados Unidos.
Y tal parece que a muchas mujeres les ocurre lo mismo.
Esta furia no era exclusivamente de mi amiga.
Su furia era el resultado
de una histórica costumbre masculina
de servirse del cuerpo de la mujer sin su consentimiento.
Hay una cultura de esta práctica
y en este caso, de una manera aparentemente inofensiva,
donde el cuerpo de la mujer recibe el trato de un salero de mesa:
"Quítate de mi camino, así llego a las papas fritas",
(Risas)
hasta las situaciones más indignantes,
violentas
y espantosas.
Intuyo que algunos se preguntarán cuál es la relación
entre lo inofensivo y lo espantoso,
dos cosas que parecen estar en los extremos opuestos del espectro.
Pues bien, el hilo común es el espectro.
Lo inofensivo da lugar a lo espantoso.
Y las mujeres debemos vivir con el efecto de ambos
y de todo lo que hay en el medio.
A los varones les pregunto,
¿se imaginan estar hablando por teléfono
y que alguien se acerque para quitárselo de la mano, así como así?
Y les digan, "Hombre, no sé por qué te fastidias,
solo quiero hacer una llamada.
Te lo devolveré en cuanto termine.
Y a otra cosa".
Y ahora imaginen si les quitan el móvil de las manos,
no sé... una vez al día,
dos veces al día,
cuando sea,
y la explicación fuese:
"Y bueno, es que tu funda me encanta",
o "No lo deberías haber sacado del bolsillo",
o "Pues bien, sí,
simplemente es así".
Pero lo cierto es que nadie habla de la persona que tomó el móvil.
Sé que es un ejemplo simplificado al extremo,
pero imaginarán adónde apunto.
Los hombres están tan acostumbrados a servirse sin permiso,
que en cierto modo no lo pueden evitar.
Y no porque los hombres sean en esencia menos éticos,
sino porque este es un gran punto ciego para la mayoría de ellos.
Cuando un hombre se sirve de una mujer,
no solo provoca angustia e incomodidad,
sino que reflota las experiencias silenciosas de nuestras madres,
de nuestras hermanas
y de generaciones de mujeres en el pasado.
Años y años de historias de mujeres que debieron lidiar con hombres
que creen saber lo que nos conviene mejor que nosotras mismas,
en nuestra condición de propiedad de los maridos,
de los dueños de la tierra,
y de hombres blancos y viejos
que deciden el destino de nuestras partes íntimas.
Años y años de mujeres que soportaron el uso de su cuerpo
como objetos del amor y del deseo,
en lugar de adueñarnos de él y usarlo a nuestro antojo.
Años y años de aceptar que, acatando o no las reglas del hombre,
todavía debemos tolerar el acoso,
el abuso
y afrentas aún peores.
Años y años de soportar que nuestro cuerpo sea una propiedad
que puede ser golpeada y lastimada,
manipulada y movida,
como objetos que no merecen respeto.
Años y años de no poder expresar la ira contenida en nuestro cuerpo.
No sorprende que sintamos esta furia.
Y si a esto le sumamos la cuestión racial,
que es todo un tema para otra charla,
se complica de manera exponencial.
Cuando una mujer es maltratada, empieza a buscar excusas,
a tratar de entender cómo ocurrió.
"Seguramente fue mi culpa.
Ya sé, me habrá dicho algo y no lo oí.
Estoy exagerando,
exagerando por demás".
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Las mujeres hemos sido adiestradas para creer que estamos exagerando,
o que somos demasiado sensibles, o poco razonables,
que le damos importancia a las tonterías,
y reprimimos ese sentimiento de furia.
Tratamos de ocultarlo en alguna parte de la mente,
pero no desaparece.
Esa furia está profundamente instalada mientras ensayamos una sonrisa,
(Ríe nerviosamente) "Sí, claro",
y tratamos de agradar,
"Lo sé" (Ríe nerviosamente) "Sí, sí, claro".
Porque, según parece, la mujer no debería enojarse.
Esa furia que mi amiga sintió encierra siglos
de represión al no canalizar ni expresar nuestra indignación,
nuestra frustración
y nuestra ira.
Cuando alguien cree que puede servirse de nuestro cuerpo,
no solo enciende la furia del momento,
sino que también ilumina el pasado.
Ese momento aparentemente tranquilo en la oficina postal
es en realidad una granada de ira.
Pues bien,
¡bum!
Hoy, la recopilación de experiencias vividas por mujeres en todo el mundo
ya no puede ser ignorada.
Se acabó la idea de que estamos exagerando
o de que "Bueno, esto es así".
Se acabó la idea de que las mujeres son señaladas como responsables
del proceder impropio del hombre.
Es responsabilidad del hombre cambiar su conducta inadecuada.
(Aplausos)
Nuestra cultura está cambiando
y ya era hora.
Por eso, compañeras
y caballeros,
desde este lugar tan particular que nos toca transitar juntos,
en este movimiento a gran escala hacia la igualdad de las mujeres,
y con la expectativa de un futuro que aún no existe,
ambos tenemos distintas misiones.
Hombres,
los convoco como aliados
en este camino conjunto hacia el cambio.
Espero que asuman su responsabilidad
y que sean reflexivos de sus propios actos,
compasivos y abiertos,
que se pregunten cómo pueden apoyar a una mujer y colaborar para el cambio
y que pidan ayuda si es necesario.
Y mujeres,
las convoco
a que reconozcan su furia,
la transformen en palabras,
la compartan en lugares de identificación seguros
y de manera segura.
No deben temerle a esa furia.
Encierra siglos de sabiduría.
Déjenla que respire
y escuchen.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.